[Applause]
Thank You dick
it's always a pleasure to come back to
Berkeley so many great memories here so
somebody was looking at my title
yesterday and and commented that he
didn't see the abstract just the title
and he said the law of clickbait says
that is if there's a question I'm a
question mark at the end of the title
then the answer is going to be no is
that the case and so not to give away
any punch lines but that's what he said
all right so yeah I was encouraged to
gear this talked with a non-technical
audience so they are
there's no sermon here and fairly a
broad overview of various things okay so
let's start with this age-old question
the oldest question in computer science
can machines think and even pioneers
like ladyada
who were thinking about computers in the
19th early 19th century were already
considering this question and she
formulated the term computers but she
said well they can't be human-like
because they don't do anything new only
they only do what oh I have a typo they
only do what we programmed them to do
and and then of course in Alan Turing's
famous work on a famous paper on
artificial intelligence here he starts
with this question there's the first
line of his famous paper and he
formulates the famous imitation game
also known as the Turing test and in
this paper he addresses nine common
objections and misconceptions including
lady errors and he points out that of
course you can program a computer to
learn from experience and and then they
would be different from the way you
program them initially so that's a very
trivial solution glade-iators objection
interesting enough I went back and read
that paper and probably for the end time
last weekend and I was reminded that
actually one of the nine
misconceptions objections he he talks
about is ESP and it seems like he
believed in ESP I had forgotten that I I
think I'd read that paper before so yeah
if you haven't read the paper recently
please go look at it it's actually kind
of interesting okay so so there's not
going to be really what I'll talk about
much at all I don't think the very
interesting question probably like most
computer scientists but a distinction
was made between strong and weak AI so
we kiii is where the machines input
output behavior is human-like how will
you define that so for instance Turing
formulated it as the famous Turing test
where the human judge is supposed to
distinguish whether their conversation
was with a machine or with a person and
strong ai's refers to again it's not
very well defined but that the machine
actually has a mind and has human-like
thought processes again it's not
specified how you would test that but
for instance it can compose symphonies
prove theorems etc now of course I don't
have any friends who can compose a
symphony so alright but I do have many
friends who prove theorem so yeah so I
think for computer scientists this
distinction has been a little nebulous
because it's not clear what a strong ear
is but I but in the interest of
surveying the kind of thinking people
have brought through questions of
artificial intelligence I wanted to just
mention that there's been a quarter
there's been a lot of controversy over
strong AI and maybe the younger people
actually may not have been exposed to it
as much because I think it's become kind
of less fashionable than it used to be
maybe 20 30 40 years ago so I briefly
survey that and then I'll move on to
computational complexity P versus NP and
and so on I briefly surveyed that and
then I'll give you a brief survey of
machine learning approaches and why
computational complexity seems to
present the hurdle this has always been
our thinking that there are some
difficult problems in this field which
is really the hurdle
not you know some of the philosophical
issues that were raised by earlier
philosophers and then I think I'll try
to suggest that actually computational
complexity is not such a big hurdle and
I'll describe some efforts that my group
made to understand just one simple
particular neural net method this is a
way of illustrating the kinds of theory
you could still do here despite the
computational complexity hood and
finally I'll I'll sketch why competition
complexity may not be hurdle after all
what's the map forward ok so the first
part is er this history the controversy
about strong AI and I want to surveyed
mainly because the instinctive reaction
of most people to the prospect of AI is
of course that it's impossible I mean
again given that these is they're
billionaires funding efforts because
they're concerned about strongly maybe
this worry that you know it's not this
way this objection that strongly I
cannot happen has maybe gone away but
this used to be very popular that people
thought it's impossible so first let's
see what's the possibility argument it's
a simulation argument that in principle
you could just simulate the human brain
ok every atom of it and I did a
calculation at about 10 to the 40 atoms
or something and if you understand the
laws of physics of elementary particles
you could simulate that in principle
even if we don't completely know the
laws now the belief is that there are
laws and so the machine could and could
encode those laws and simulate which of
course leads to all kinds of
philosophical issues which which are
very popular with science fiction
writers you know namely for instance if
it's that's all it is to the brain to my
brain then you could just take a core
dump of the brain and then would you
have two copies of me right so those
kinds of philosophical questions but ah
but it seems so plausible that that
could be a way to just get some kind of
in principle in a machine it's a proof
of concept it's clearly impractical even
many many decades into the future
because we really don't understand
anything about the or not a lot about
how the brain works as the neuron level
let alone at the atom level in fact
there is a warm out there C elegans a
beloved warm in biology
whose brain was actually mapped
completely the connectome has been
understood for 30 years almost for
actually 30 years exactly 302 neurons
5000 synapses and we still don't know
how to simulate that or predict what
it's going to do so this reductionist
approach the simulation argument is in
principle seems ok but in practice is
going to be very difficult ok then here
at Berkeley John Searle the philosophers
also attempted to show impossibility of
strong AI his famous Chinese room
thought experiment and he actually it's
an interesting flipping around of the
simulation argument so we computer
scientists thing ok with the computer
you can simulate the world and he's
saying well design any computer that
passes Turing test in Chinese ok well
it's because you know it's made of logic
gears and so on it's simulate able by a
group of humans ok so like each logic
gate is handed out to one human and now
the computer is this consists of logic
gates communicating with each other so
these people who each of whom control
the logic gate can communicate amongst
each other using the computers program
and they follow that and then they can
speak Chinese ok if the computer was
speaking Chinese and then Searle says
via the simulation argument while
clearly none of this room of English
speakers understood Chinese and
therefore needed at the computer how
many people how many people in this room
is this at all convincing
I don't know you sir are you John Cyril
or so okay yeah so I I used to teach a
course for freshmen non-majors where is
the last lecture we we read souls paper
and related writings and these all
non-majors and I was actually shocked
you know to me clearly this is delicious
but because all because all it's saying
is you know a computer's made of gates
right that's not ruling out anything
right it was it's only saying computers
middle gate guys that doesn't you know
so and in my non-majors class that we'd
go on over gates then you know how the
gear works and everything right so but
except for a couple of students
everybody found this very convincing you
know there's a little bit more to this
you know he wraps it up in more kind you
know the computer doesn't eat and
doesn't digest things you know it cannot
have human processes that way so anyway
so that just you know yeah most of this
room this seems fallacious but but when
you present it to Princeton freshmen
they find it really convincing okay so
of course the obvious rebuttal is that
you know message passing among large
simple simple organisms can be very
powerful of course at some level our
bodies like that right the cells are
communicating with each other there's
intelligence and colony and so have very
sophisticated social hierarchies they do
agriculture war etc which is all
implemented by simple message passing
and soul forgets to point out that you
know if you have a room of people which
are simulating each gate in a modern CPU
well this room would contain about 10 to
the 10 people that's more than number of
people in on earth and I did a
calculation would be the size of
Connecticut assuming every person is has
a space of this much
and finally in the last 20-30 years
people have studied consciousness and
there is accumulating evidence of a lot
of what we think of as consciousness is
any illusion and it is an emergent
phenomenon that there are various
processes going on and somehow they
mediate amongst each other and the
result is consciousness so yeah so this
but so this argument said is not very
convincing to me at all but it has had a
lot of currency and then there's a clean
impossibility of strongly adverse via
go-to theorem and with some smidgen of
quantum mechanics so it apparently dates
back to Lucas the philosopher and then
revived by Penrose the famous physicist
in the 1980s and the idea was the idea
and this is that when you're trying to
suppose you start off by thinking okay I
intuitively I don't believe in strong AI
or AI of any kind how I'm going to
refute it well there aren't so many
mathematical ways of refuting things
okay like something so vast and
ill-defined right it's not like some
simple system and you're proving
disproving or proving something it's
like a big idea of strong AI and if I'm
to refute it so you latch on to whatever
has happened in mathematics in recent
decades and in this case they latch on
to go to the theorem which says many
things are many go to theorems but let's
say roughly it's the construction of
goal sentence which asserts a
consistency of safety on orous metric
which is an axiomatic system for number
theory and the special sentence happens
to be true humans think it's true but
it's not provable in piano at night okay
or so in general go to sentence can be
applied to any logical system for
reasoning so the idea is that this
your computer is the system for logical
reasoning therefore it prob'ly cannot
realize the truth of go to special
sentence say concerning the center
consistency of an arithmetic but a human
can okay that's in a nutshell argument
I'm possibly not doing full justice to
it but but that's the idea and Penrose
revived this argument and he gave a
stronger version of it which is still
controversial and then he goes on to
suggest on this basis that a human brain
is not a classical logical system like
this and that somehow quantum gravity
phenomena in the brain play an important
role in in how human insight and
intelligence arises and that book caused
a firestorm certainly in computer
science circles and yeah so yeah it's
you can spend a few evenings reading the
back and forth on this it's somewhat
interesting but it seems to me that at
best it says at best even if you take it
completely take this argument completely
at face level at best it says that
computers may occasionally make mistakes
very very occasionally
right when they're presented with such a
strange input the go-to sentence which
may be a well trained mathematician
might not so at best it says that so
it's not clear what that refutes because
most people on earth would not be able
to make sense of that sentence either
yeah so my feeling is that go theorem
has no place in this discussion at least
not a very interesting one so I wanted
to just yeah so we survey that
controversy which was amusing at a time
and of course these days people are it
is a opposite controversy where a lot of
the common public she believes that
strongly eyes around the corner
and worried about it okay so the next
part is computational complexity P
versus NP so computational complexity
where for instance Nik had a very very
seminal role was invented to to prove
limitations on computers so the next
step forward beyond the work of touring
girdle etc which proved undecidability
and this was about the limitations of
computers with finite resources which is
what real-life computers are so theory
of computation complexity you try to
characterize competition time needed to
solve a problem and what does it mean to
characterize the computation time needed
to solve a problem ideally you should
design an algorithm that runs in some
time T on inputs of a certain size and B
if you want to characterize it
completely you should show that no other
algorithm running in much less than T
times solves the problem if you can do
that you've characterized the
computation time near to solve a problem
and you can similarly try to
characterize other resources like memory
or communication so so of course the
algorithm design is a is an important
and active area so we have many we've
designed many good algorithms over the
decade but this has been much less
successful to prove the limitations of
computers running in even quadratic time
it's completely open completely we have
no idea how to prove like a computer
takes more than quadratic time heck more
than n log in time okay to solve
problems any problems any interesting
problems so there's very little progress
on B and so when we try to prove B we
try to prove it modulo famous
conjectures and this is where the work
of dick and Steve cook and the owner 11
comes in on P versus NP so P standing
for polynomial time consists of the
class of problems where the solution can
be found in poly
time time polynomial in the input sizes
and at the input size the running time
is n to the C n square and cube so on
and he is where a good solution can be
checked in n to the C time polynomial
time so if somebody provides you with
the correct solution you can check that
it's the correct solution this may be a
little bit counterintuitive to even
imagine for most people what is the
problem where once you're given a
solution you can't check it but there
are many such problems for example
problems in robotics you know because
there's iterative the decisions that
have to be made so the set of all the
solution is really a very large tree and
so you cannot really check very large
tree in polynomial time ok it cannot
even be presented to a machine that runs
in polynomial time so so there are
problems very natural ones where that
property is not true but where it is
true that's NP + NP complete the class
identified by dick and others where is
the class of problems in NP such that
every other NP problem is reducible to
instances of this problem in polynomial
time so examples are travelling salesmen
maxcut satisfiability integer
programming problems of others so in
some sense the np-complete problems are
the hardest problems of NP because if
they have a polynomial time algorithm
then every NP problem would so normally
P which is NP is phrased as a locally
saying can brilliance or creativity be
automated why does it why does it have
that intuitive connotation because NP
consists of solutions that can be
checked in problem that so if so think
about your math homework maybe you don't
want to think about it math homework
here but if you think about your math
homework if it's very difficult to come
up with a good solution but once you
come up with one or somebody gives you
the solution you can check it very
easily right so it takes brilliance to
come up with a solution but no
brilliance or not a lot of brilliance to
check it so if P equals NP it's saying
that if a good solution exists
you can find it in Paloma plan okay so
that's why brilliant sought creativity
can be automated and if P is not equal
to NP then np-complete problems cannot
be solved in polynomial time why because
if P is not equal to NP there is at
least one problem in NP which cannot be
solved in polynomial time and therefore
certainly the np-complete problems which
are the hardest problem cannot be solved
in polynomial
so complexity of the obstacle to AI well
the simplest complexity of obstacle is
that dozens if not hundreds of AI
problems that arise naturally in AI are
np-complete and here's a very simple
example that are encountered in grad
school which I think Christos is not
here today but curious and papademetriou
a very low-level problem you know
recognizing polyhedral scenes so in
other words is this sketched polyhedron
a real polyhedron or something that
doesn't exist in real life
ok so for instance D is not a real
polyhedron ok so it's something that MCS
show might a shemite micro ok so that so
recognizing valid polyhedral scenes is
np-complete ok so and there are dozens
or hundreds of such other results and
and this is already suggest to you that
you know NP completeness may arise in
very stylized or very specialized in ok
the hardness may manifest itself as that
and NP hardness only concerns difficulty
of woodson of the problem ok and does
it's only relevant if we desire an
algorithm that works for every input and
so in that sense it's a little NP
hardness result is somewhat
philosophically similar to the results
on Guru theorem because goes theorem
also at least my conclusion was that at
best that argument against AI is just
saying that occasionally you might be
able to come up with a question which
Woodfox the machine but not a
well-trained mathematician maybe so in
that sense yeah this
the instance that you would the
np-hardness result would give you some
very stylized or very complicated
instances of this polyhedral recognition
problem but it may never arise in
practice okay so it's important to
realize that but in the mean time as a
result as a result of continuing
investigation into complexity theory
including the PCP theorem which dick
alluded to now we know that actually NP
completeness also implies difficulty of
computing approximate solutions so after
they can others discovered NP
completeness dig himself
which one of the pioneers in suggesting
that you could potentially get around
this bad news of NP completeness by
shooting for approximate solution so a
solution that you know 99% correct and I
won't even formally define that but
intuitively you could imagine what that
might so it's 99% correctly so a priori
the the theory of NP completeness did
not rule out that approximations are
difficult so it could be that P is not
equal to NP but all these empty complete
problems have very good approximation
algorithms in which case NP completeness
wouldn't be such bad news but turns out
that as a result of this few decades of
work and we now know that for actually
most of the interesting problems that
were studied in this theory actually
even approximation is hard so so what
does that mean so just illustrating so
suppose these are all instances for the
Traveling Salesman problem okay if you
haven't seen the Traveling Salesman
problem don't worry about it it's some
problem in optimization and suppose you
have an algorithm that computes a 10%
approximation so it gets within 10% of
the optimum on all instances of problem
salesmen what these results are saying
is that whoops that I can leverage that
algorithm to actually solve any
np-complete problem
okay so for instance if you take a hard
instance of boolean satisfiability
involving factoring integers or whatever
you take the heart in terms of wooden
sides are the one you are interested in
these results give a ways to transform
that hard instance of boolean
satisfiability into an instance of
traveling salesmen so it's got cities
and distances among cities and so on and
you can use your 10% approximation
algorithm okay so yeah so you can map
this instance to an instance of
traveling salesman and then you can use
the 10% approximation algorithm to then
solve satisfiability exactly not
approximately okay so 10% approximation
to traveling salesman would solve
satisfiability exactly okay so what this
means is that if you believe that
satisfiability or np-complete problems
are hard then even compute an
approximate solutions is drawing
salesmen it's hard okay
and this this kind of bad news is now
known for a lot of problems and in fact
we know that that is the approximation
ratio that's hard is actually the
approximation ratio of the bestower for
many such problem so the algorithms we
have right now are going to be optimal
okay unless if there's some bad you know
some of these complexity conjectures are
false so on the one hand it's a huge
crime for complexity theory ok we've
sort of characterized for many of these
problems the best algorithm even ok
modulo P versus NP but the bad news are
saying philosophically is that this is
really unexpected you know that hardness
is so ubiquitous okay the fact that this
can be done for lots of problems not
just travelling salesmen it's kind of
unexpected ok and as somebody who has
been in this field the approximation
field since pretty much the beginning or
fairly early I would say you know many
of these hardness results were like a
punch to the gut you know I was really
hoping some of these problems would be
easy and they were hard ok they're hard
to approximately
okay so computational hodges the bad
news is even worse than we suspected
okay but that's all for worst-case
complexity okay if you're interested in
solving the worst case and the question
is whether that's relevant machinery
okay so let's see so what are some some
approaches for machine learning and
machine learning has add various phases
and no phase really goes away because
the old phases still apply to some
interesting settings and people keep
studying them and I know many people
here might be interested in deep deep
nets we'll get to them in a few slides
so so there's a logic based approach
that arose out of the logic work sort of
in a sense the descendant of the work of
gödel Turing etc and I was also looking
at McCarthy's paper programs with common
sense so you can see that good marketing
has been with AI since the beginning so
so that so that paper was sketching this
logic based approach where you will have
a database of fact and system for
logically disease deducing new facts
from these so things like all birds can
fly to it pretty the bird if it's witty
can fly and this is of course I'm
writing in words but you can formalize
it using logic and the hope was that the
logic would be the basis of this kind of
reasoning and actually there are people
out there right now I've heard of actual
names you know people who are who have
them and their group you know grad
students whatever volunteers who are
busy adding axioms like for common sense
through some database and there are up
to million axioms and Counting and the
hope is that you know once the machine
knows enough facts about the world right
that men have usually two hands and you
know these kinds of things at some point
the system is sort of complete or
complete enough and we'll have common
sense reasoning so so this still
continues
okay so many programming environments
were developed for symbolically
expressing and solving such reasoning
problems very interesting and important
work but the practical difficulty is
that it's very tedious for programming
to code and millions of practical
machine and but clearly it's a very
general reasoning system okay now how
does complexity relate to this well
deduction problem in very simple logical
systems is np-complete even
propositional logic so so in the worst
case this will have no polynomial time
algorithm so yeah so the fact that did
this this is not difficult to make this
is not easy to make it work you know one
might suspect that then P completeness
is something to do with it maybe okay so
the next idea are dating to the 80s and
this was very very popular in machine
learning and the dominant approach is
Bayesian reasoning where you try to have
a probabilistic model of the world of
data and and then you compute on these
probabilistic models to do inference
kinds of problems so roughly speaking
there's it's a probabilistic analog of
logical reasoning I apologize for this
smudgy picture pixelated but yeah it's a
Bayes net is some kind of a description
of the world where in this case this is
a standard example from Stuart Russell
and Norvig textbook on artificial
intelligence so this events happening in
the world like whether there's a fire
whether this smoke alarm if your alarm
is ringing or not and and so on okay so
so each of these in this graph of in
this graph denotes relationship split
between the events and if this event
does happen that there's a fire then
smoke happens with some probability and
alarm goes off with some probability etc
okay so so you specify the word in this
probabilistic sense so it's kind of like
logical actions but with probabilities
on them and and then deduction is to
compute the probability of a certain
variable being one conditioned on the
known values of some other variables and
this problem is also empty
I didn't define np-hard it's more or
less like np-complete let's I want
cutter defined precisely so this problem
is np-hard
okay so again yeah it's very attractive
and in general in machine learning if
you're trying to describe the world in
some sense you naturally need some kind
of probabilities because a deterministic
description of the world even if it's
correct even if you believe the world is
deterministic the way it and it unfolds
for us right in our experience it has
probably isn't it
right we can't really predict what's
going to happen even if the world is the
ground truth is deterministic which is
probably not true either
so yeah you need some kind of
probabilities you need some kind of
causality kinds of things and and so
this seems like clearly a very relevant
way of thinking about the world and
progress was made using algorithms
heuristic arguments but in worst case
this is np-hard as well
kernel SVM's so it's an example of
learning from data so the idea is that
you're given example so think of these
assay images and images I expressed
using some features whether the image
has certain features so each image is a
vector now okay a vector of features and
the blue images are examples of birds
and red images are examples of animals
or not birds and the goal is to learn a
classifier separating captain on cat
oops sorry I birds and non good sorry
okay sorry weather and so the idea and
kernel SVM was to come up with and I
come up with an algorithm or a
methodology which is prove the
polynomial time so in some sense it was
a reaction to NP completeness okay that
we're going to have cool will algorithms
which run in polynomial time and indeed
these problems can be solved via convex
programming programming in polynomial
time and the idea is that yeah there's
some kind of a feature space and you map
these points into this feature space and
then you come up with a simple
classifier for
since this half space okay so points on
this side blue points on this side of
the hospice and red points on this side
and in general you may allow this method
to make errors and so on and there's a
nice very nice beautiful theory of
statistical learning which exactly
explains under what conditions this
works okay so but in practice has
limited success on very difficult
classification problems it works very
well on simple problems if you have a
simple machine learning setting and you
want something easy not a lot of it you
don't have a lot of data try this it'll
probably do a reasonable job but if you
have something complicated like actually
separating words from non boards or
something pictures of words from on
board is not going to work very well so
what does work well probably most people
in this room anybody who's read any
newspaper in the last five years I would
know that yeah this is the dominant
approach these days and those kinds of
difficult problems recognize an image
recognition it's called deep learning
it's inspired by originally by the by
the neurons in the brain this line of
work goes goes back six or seven decades
going back to the discovery of the
neurons in the brain and how they work
and so the idea is that you have these
simple computational units the popular
one these days is called a relegate but
before that there were other kinds of
neuronal gates that were studied
so the relegate is this is a relegate
and the incoming edges are from other
gates so if the other gates are values
x1 x2 so on up to xn this relegate
computes a weighted sum of x1 to xn so
that this thing so it has each of these
edges has a weight on it call it an
app's weight so these are numbers real
numbers w1 through WN and you compute a
weighted sum of x1 through xn so that
this weighted come add some threshold
theta and relu and value is this
function this nonlinear function which
is 0 below in the negative side and and
just X on the positive side so that's a
relegate and
the modern dipnet often is has this kind
of structure relegate which are
connected with edges and what are the
what are these synapse weights on the
edges
that's the parameters of the deep net
which are trains okay so you
the machine has this graph of these
gates and the edges connecting these
gates have some synapse weights which
are the parameters of the net and those
parameters are going to be twins and
they are trained using this classic
algorithm by Romo hard at all called
back propagation and just that classic
algorithm applied on modern data sets
and modern computers those beautifully
okay so this is the famous work of
Rossetti era which revived this peel and
yeah so that's the neural net Ernest in
a in a nutshell and and there's been a
an explosion of work on this in the last
five years and at this point there's
better than human accuracy on image
classification using hundreds of layers
and millions of edges in these nets when
I mentioned that I would mention this
figure somewhere before and people asked
what I mean better than human accuracy
because the data said was created by
humans right so the data said data set
is basically pictures collected from the
internet and with labels a thousand
different labels you know it's a cat or
doll water well so it was all labeled by
humans so people said how can you train
a network which using humanly labeled
data and get superhuman performance and
the answer is that it's better than any
individual human the individual humans
may have like a 95% accuracy rate but if
you aggregate over the wisdom of crowds
right so then you can get much better
accuracy and the neural net screen on
that aggregated wisdom of the crowd and
that's why it's better than human
accuracy
okay now complexity theory says that
learning even a shallow net with one
eight
and rattle okay that this thing cannot
work and there in various various
results for instance Clevenger school
but as you as I mentioned earlier
complexity only rules out some very the
hardness of very complex
complicated instance which in this case
means some very strange data set with
strange labels okay
not real life images with humanly
provided labels it's some crazy data set
with strange labels okay and and those
those would be then creating a neural
net to it would be hard but on real life
data set it seems not so this so the
emerging lesson in computational
complexity appears to be that that for
Monnet most natural problems in natural
phrasing is computationally intractable
maybe even hard to approximate and so on
okay and it's not I mean these are not
these are only these are not very
well-defined notions natural problems
natural phrasing but you know the kind
of phrasing that we come up with using
our normal mathematical training but
this does not mean that the problem is
intractable in practice and in fact it
may even be solvable at industrial fever
so this is the emerging lesson about
complexity so so why is NP hardness not
an obstacle to it so just to drive in
that that point I just made that in
machine learning you're interested in
some real life data set like
understanding a text corpus you want
some kind of understanding and so that
corresponds to this set of instances
okay so articles written by humans like
Wikipedia and then you come up with a
mathematical phrasing of this which
might involve okay I have these vectors
and I have this matrix or things like
that and that corresponds to putting a
much bigger oval around it a much bigger
box around it because in that phrasing
you are allowing in all kinds of
very weird instances right any vector
any matrix and so on and so that's a
much bigger box of instances so let's
say you know learning topic models you
know it just doesn't matter what the
problem is it's some well-defined
mathematical problem with you know given
such answers input you desire such and
such output and and now when somebody
proves that it's np-hard
and again just emphasizing what NP
hardness mean it means that there exist
difficult instances in this bounding box
so there are these instances vectors
matrices whatever which are encoding the
sat and and that doesn't say anything
about you already knows okay and so in
particular this there could be a smaller
bounding box you could draw around this
which might be completely easy okay and
there are now instances of this of this
moment for instance for this problem
learning topic models they are now ways
to define a more circumscribed or much
smaller bounding box and then that
cannot be easy polynomial time actually
that that was a paper from my group a
few years ago and their papers from
other people as well okay so so the my
point here is that if you're trying to
use NP hardness to understand difficulty
and and this goes back to go to the
theorem as well the same issue that what
this bounding boxes you know your
mathematical definition of what
intelligence is what understanding is is
a human construct it depends on your
mathematical training you know who your
advisor was and so on whether you had
coffee that morning and it's a it's a
human construct and somebody else some
some colleague from physics or economics
may define the problem completely
differently they have a different
training okay so there are infinitely
many set bounding boxes and np-hardness
just refers to the intractability of
this one particular phrasing so that's
the mismatch between NP hardness results
and understanding reality so this is
this is in the remaining few minutes I
want to talk about this you know how do
you do this
okay and and I will indeed use the
efforts to understand one particular
neural net algorithm which I'll this
right now so this has to do with solving
natural language processing tasks with
with recurrent deep net so a problems
like classification automatic
translation between languages question
answering systems etc the
state-of-the-art systems now use this
kind of deepness that I'm going to talk
about in fact the companies like Google
are now rolling out in the last few
months new translations if you go to
Google Translate it's much much improved
using some of these ideas okay so how
does the deep net understand language
so obviously understanding is somehow
captured you know after you train it
it's captured in the parameters of
Evenor right those weights on the edges
so but how do you train that so a rough
answer in these recurrent deep nets one
language is that you train the deep net
to correctly predict the next word given
the previous keywords okay so that's the
that's the black box all your training
is to predict the next word now if you
think about it in order to correctly if
I give you the first half of the
sentence allows you to predict what
comes next
you would need to implicitly understand
grammar some common sense because some
sentences you need common sense to
complete and and some usage statistics
and so on
so so a foot deep net is able to do this
it must have learned something
non-trivial so so here's a simple neural
net for language understanding so you
want to find the best parameters theta
so okay sorry here I'm just rephrasing
that the neural medicine parameters
theta and given the last keyword it's
trying to predict the next one so that
so the next word there's some
probability distribution words you're
trying to find the best data such that
you fit the empirical distribution in
the back okay given the last keywords
what's the next look you try to predict
that as well as you can and there's a
famous paper of
Mikal overall at Google team called were
to whack which use a very simple
recurrent neural net where it's going to
the parameters of the neural net are
very simple it just has a vector for
every word okay at 300 dimensional
vector for every word so for every word
W there is a three dimensional vector so
represent every dictionary word with the
trainer dimensional vector and now the
probability of the next word given the
last five words is proportional to
exponential of the inner product B W and
the average of the last Bible okay so
the neural net gets negative feed for
the feedback of the actual next word at
high probability and negative feedback
otherwise that's the training algorithm
so turns out that these word vectors can
be used to solve analogies okay so the
analogies are like manage to woman s
king is two and the idea is that you
take the vector for man and the vector
for woman take the difference and now
you take the vector for king and you
look for the word such that this
difference is as close to this vector as
possible and out of all dictionary words
that word happens to be queen okay so
that's a analogy task it solves it very
well and in general you see that yeah
these this masculine/feminine
relationship corresponds to some
approximately two line in space and the
question is why does Ellen find such
vectors what property of language does
is through play okay so this is a kind
of questions I'm very interested in like
you can throw a deep net at some problem
and get some very nice results but you
get these vectors and why do they have
these properties okay so I'm very
interested in that and and I'll suggest
to you that you can actually do theory
with it so similarly there are sentence
and paragraph and bearings so for
instance if you want to know which pair
of sentences are more similar and then
out of these five which are the most
similar sentences for one and four and
the point is there are no words in
common this is not the traditional
string similarity right there's some
kind of semantic similarity it's not the
string matching and there's no words in
common between this and it but some
other very similar so so it seems like
yeah there's something magic going on
and people use neural nets oh so can you
have a sort of simple so you has a deep
net
the vector and then similarities vector
in a product but what what is going on
so a popular question about deep nets
you know one is that the optimization
problem is non convex so the
optimization surfaces this peaks and
valleys so a simple algorithm like that
propagation why does it find a good
solution as opposed to convex where it
would be guaranteed and but in fact the
same question can be asked so deep nets
and I'll just very popular but the same
question can be asked also about all
many other previous ML approaches as
well such as Bayesian method there are
also the natural problems with non
convex and and difficult by the way
sponsored link there is a blog I earn
more chart a new faculty member here and
they should personally run off convex at
work okay so so I think the more
important question in my opinion you
know then the optimization one is what
is the structure of data that they are
capturing and can the same structure be
captured by simpler algorithms so how
much then go ahead I'm almost out of
time
so explaining word of sentence embedding
so the idea is that we have this
semantic model of language production
which says that there was a semantic
signal in the writers head and there was
a word production model which leads to
output of text and we have this word
production model which which is a log
linear topic model me and handsome so it
is conceptually there is a semantic
space in your head which is this sphere
and each direction in this space is
something you could talk about which we
call it discourse and words are things
in your head which also associated with
a vector which is a word embedding and
we have this word production model that
the corpus is generated by like
Wikipedia by a random walk of discourses
in this space and as if this random walk
happens words get output according to
this log linear distribution okay so I'm
out of time so the details are maybe not
so important it's some very simple
distribution and so here's a random walk
happening which is generating this text
okay and so the model predictions you
know so you can analyze this model it's
a clean mathematical model we analyze it
under some assumptions and we find that
it validates many things that
been studied in natural language
processing so there's the old PMI rule
for word frequencies and word embeddings
so this PMI is a measure of similarity
of words or correlational word these
famous methods work the work and glove
are approximate inference algorithms for
a model for a probabilistic model and we
give another inference album that uses
weighted SVD which is np-hard but can be
solved in polynomial time under
reasonable assumption we show formally
that relations correspond to line we
give an explanation for this the fact
that I alluded to in a couple of slides
ago so with a slight modification of
this model we can get very simple and
understandable sentence embeddings very
very simple I could explain it to you in
a minute
which are competitive with those phone
using recurrent neural Nets for many
tasks ok the reviewers are very
surprised
ok so that brings me to the final thing
that will do a 1-1 slide really propose
the agenda for theoretical machine
learning and advice for students and
referees referees because you know the
moisture fries are still very much fond
of the the older view which is very much
focused on you know hardness and convex
formulations so the first agenda item is
to look beyond NP hardness and look
beyond usual convex formulation and
there's been a slew of work in the last
few years which approved the efficient
elements for many np-hard problems under
some reasonable assumptions and these
items really work well in practice they
use linear algebra and quite quite
reasonably efficient in some cases they
are actually more efficient than the old
are would be where the minimum
description length aesthetic it likely
leads to a hard problem
so as you saw you know when we started
to understand word embeddings and
sentence embedding you have to make some
assumptions you make you come up with a
model then go and test model I forgot to
mention that we tested that model so
when you do that it's not minimum
description length which is in the
popular mode and in the article work
which is very much influenced by
mathematics the fewest assumptions will
just need to
a hard problem and that's not
necessarily the best theorem and finally
combine math with modeling namely making
assumptions and it's a little bit more
like physics than econ and I think
theory has been much more influenced by
math in its taste and maybe we'll have
partial theorems or these theorems that
illuminate a little aspect of it so to
conclude AI is this elephant in the room
and there are many different types of
communities looking at AI are including
theoretical ml community and we are a
little bit like line men in the room a
blind man with the elephant and we have
our own ticks but I'm sure that theory
plus mass will play a big role in this
endeavor despite the earlier feeling
that maybe their heart is there but I
think I'm pretty sure that you're in
math would say a big role in this and
they were and illuminating thank you
very much
[Applause]